foreign
Jade the Department of Education has
issued guidance to student loan
companies to begin collecting payments
in September so you mean these people
really want their money back and you
mean the president's actually going to
let them do it
he's announced that he's running for
reelection I know now he's going to make
you pay your student loans is he though
do you think he's going to try to kick
it down the can kick the can down the
road one more time no you think this is
it I think I don't think the Department
of Education would have put this notice
out if they weren't going to do it
because they've not done this in the
future that's true that is a very good
point all of the other deadlines that
we're approaching they were silent
that's true he kicked the candy kicked
the candy kicked the can and this time I
think he's going to do it now I have to
have another I have to have an alternate
Theory and that would be okay so when we
get up closer to election
uh it's going to come up that he didn't
really forgive the student loans of
course unless he does something again
so expect another announcement
during the election year but also expect
to start paying your payments again in
September that's true and I can't help
but think about the effect of this on
folks because I think the average
student loan payment is about 480 and
people have gotten I mean it's been
three years people have gotten so used
to three years three years that's
unbelievable
that's crazy and people have I mean it's
this is your lifestyle now people bought
houses
based off of that they don't have their
student loan payments yes and they
bought cars Dave based on
loan payments they bought look they
traded in that 480 student loan payment
for Carno for 480 yeah but don't waste a
good crisis because we had a we had a
quarantine that was in in our area was
about 30 days yeah and um
but we got three good years out of it
three years
so I won against the crisis I just
wondered Dave when when those payments
hit August 31st is supposed to be that
that magic date and I just wonder how
this is going to affect people's
Financial world I mean think about it
people overspent like crazy here's the
other thing from a political standpoint
you gotta think about this you can't
wait until just before the election to
do this if he does it now they're going
to be pissed off at him that's what I'm
saying well forget about it by November
next
yeah that's true so people have the
attention span of a Nat they don't
remember they can't stay pissed off for
a whole year yeah and so 14 months
that's true so that that it's really I
mean you have to know that these are
Political Animals and these Political
Animals function a hundred percent of
the time on Instinct and the instinct is
politics it is not reality they may or
may not forget they may forget it
depends on the outcome don't forget it
because if this if this causes folks to
have to change their lifestyle well they
might still be bitter
don't forget don't forget
because they can't they I'm telling you
this
you're right though I mean you're right
people do forget quickly yeah I mean so
the White House announced last November
the federal student loan payments would
resume 60 days after the education
department is allowed to initiate its
student loan forgiveness plan or after
the Supreme Court litigation is resolved
whichever comes first in February the
Supreme Court heard arguments
against President Biden student loan
forgiveness plan and they're expected to
issue a rolling
in late June or early July and so
basically they've given him a tip of the
hat and said uh we are not going to rule
in your favor that's what it is and so
July plus 60
there it is yeah July plus 60. wow it's
an omen what's activating it is the
Supreme Court thing yeah so he's going
to lose yeah he knows it and they're
being kind by giving him this
forewarning yes
well they weren't supposed to do that
but they do that and now this is your
warning to get your budding Gear Well I
mean why did you get ready for that did
you think it was going to go away Dave
people thought they thought wrong I know
think
ing is a lost art form